some breaking news from the house of
commons and uh let's get the very latest
who else to ask but of course tamara hi
hi kay this is a report by the standards
committee which looks into misconduct
involving mps and they found there has
been misconduct relating to the former
cabinet minister owen patterson he used
to be environment secretary now they
were looking into him because he was
working as a paid consultant for two
private companies one called randox and
one called lynn's country foods and they
were concerned that he had lobbied the
food standards agency and a government
department to make certain changes
without declaring his interest as a
consultant for which he was paid three
times his mp's salary they also say he
breached the code by using his
parliamentary office for at least 16
meetings with the with this company now
they say this is an egregious breach of
the rules one of them explain just let's
break this down why is it against the
rules because mps are allowed to take on
paid consultant jobs but they have to be
very clear in declaring that
not just in the register of expenses but
if they are asking questions that are
related to that company they need to
make clear that they have an interest in
are being paid and particularly if
you're on the front bench yes but he is
not he's a backbencher now but any mp
has to do that and
they say that he did not do that he
should have known better essentially
and
that this is they've never seen
essentially so many breaches now he says
that what he did was he believes in the
public interest they say that they um
they don't accept that explanation and
have recommended that he be suspended
from the house of commons for 30 days
and the government has five days to make
that happen um interestingly kay um if
he is suspended for 30 days that means
what's called a recall petition can be
opened which is when the voters can
decide whether they want to
call a by-election and not have him as
their mp anymore yeah that's right so if
10 of the voters in his constituency
decide that they don't want to have him
as their mp anymore it could lead to a
by-election now must be said owen
patterson is in a very safe conservative
seat and there he's had a distressing
year his wife rose took her own life
last summer he said that this inquiry he
said rather controversy this inquiry was
a big factor in that so not sure if it
will get that far but certainly it is a
it is possible that he could
have a by-election and uh lose as an mp
did the committee acknowledge what he
had been saying about his wife's death
they did they say that he has obviously
had a distressing year and they say that
may account for what they just described
as some of his behavior in responding to
the committee's accusations
they say that he's been very
aggressively defending himself but they
say that the aggravating factors um that
they would note in this case are that um
that they've never seen a case of paid
advocacy with so many breaches or such a
clear pattern of failing to separate his
public work from his private interests
and he has they say brought parliament
into disrepute by doing that and that's
a big deal that is a big deal yes so in
summary in summary owen patterson former
cabinet minister did paid lobbying
didn't declare it properly it's an
egregious breach of the rules and he
could possibly for a few steps to take
and lose his seat as an mp okay thanks
very much indeed thank you thanks a lot